i don't really
like risk for risk's sake or anything
it's and and i do think that um
early things are are very risky
uh with a low chance of success but
if you want to try to come up with an
innovative breakthrough
that's kind of that's going to be how it
is
anything
which is significantly innovative is
going to come with a significant risk of
failure
and
but you know if you've got to take big
chances in order for the potential for a
big
positive outcome
um
and um
you know just if and if i mean if the
outcome is exciting enough then then
taking a big risk is worthwhile yeah
it's really
i approach it but but then once
executing down a path i actually do my
absolute best to
reduce uh risk you know because
or to improve the another way of saying
to improve the probability of success
because uh
when you try to do something that is
very um
very risky
uh
that you ha you you have to spend a lot
of effort trying to reduce that risk as
you embark down that path
i mean when
um when i started spacex the i thought
the odds of success were very low
um i thought we'd most likely
fail
but i thought well
we should give it a try nonetheless
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get the seven
best lessons from elon musk jeff bezos
bill gates and other billionaire
entrepreneurs
enjoy
lesson number two minimize stress with
jeff bezos i laugh a lot
so it is
you know there are
i think stress you can be
one of the things that's very important
to note about stress is that stress
primarily comes
from not taking action over something
that you can have some control over
so if i find that some particular thing
is causing me to have stress that's a a
a warning flag for me what it means is
there's something that i haven't
completely identified perhaps in my
conscious mind
that is
bothering me and i haven't yet taken any
action on it i find as soon as i
identify it and make the first phone
call or send off the first email message
or whatever it is that we're going to do
to start to address that situation even
if it's not solved the mere fact that
we're addressing it dramatically reduces
any stress that might come from it so
stress comes
from ignoring things that you shouldn't
be ignoring
i think in large part so
stress doesn't come people get stressed
wrong all the time in my opinion
stress doesn't come from hard work
for example you know you can be working
incredibly hard and loving it and
likewise you can be out of work and
incredibly stressed over that
so and likewise if you kind of use the
you know use that as an analogy for what
i was just talking about if you're out
of work but you're going through you
know a disciplined approach of you know
a series of job interviews and so on and
working to remedy that situation you're
going to be a lot less stressed than if
you're just worrying about it and doing
nothing lesson number three enjoy what
you do with bill gates i've chosen to
spend my time and
melinda spends her time building the
foundation as an institution that really
has an impact and i get a lot of
enjoyment this is you know how i've
taken everything i've learned from
microsoft and the position i'm in and
helping to drive the strategy
and go out and and see what's going on
with this work that's my full-time
job
and it's a wonderful job
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there lesson number four have compassion
with oprah winfrey having compassion for
other people is at the top of that list
i would say commitment is at the top of
that list and also a spirit of
constructive engagement and by
compassion i don't just mean sympathy it
certainly isn't pity it's being present
and it's also
feeling with other beings you know
during the years of the oprah show i
interviewed over 37 000 people one on
one
so whenever i'm telling my girls
anything and they say they start rolling
their eyes like oh
i'm the only person you going to talk to
talk to 37 000 people
so if i were you i would pay attention
but during all those years of talking to
over 37 000 people one on one
i could feel what they were feeling so
strongly sometimes it made me sick
literally
so i had to learn how to
feel how others were feeling feel with
others which
is which is what it means to be
compassionate to feel with others
without taking in all of their stuff
being compassionate means i feel
with
you
it is one of the greatest qualities in
the world to have if you're going to be
uh
majoring in what it takes to be a great
human being i feel with you
means i not only am willing to walk in
your shoes
it means my heart beats with yours
it means i see myself in you it means
i
may not have shared that circumstance
but i know what heartbreak feels like i
know what pain feels like and all pain
is the same
it means
i can feel your will to want to do
better and be better and i feel and i am
with you in spite of everything that's
happened to you
i
feel your need to rise i want to help
you rise i want to rise with you lesson
number five focus on the details with
richard branson we set up three airlines
um virgin australia
virgin america and virgin atlantic and
um and they've all been very successful
um
and they've been successful um
i think well i mean most businesses are
successful because of the people but the
people
uh
only excel
if you give them the tools to do a great
job and if they if they feel like sure
and um
so i think um you know what was critical
in virgin atlantic was that all every
single little detail um was right so we
were the you know we were the first
airline
to introduce seat back videos and
five years before british airways and
you know kids who traveled on on virgin
uh would not let their parents travel on
any other airline bishop they wanted to
they wanted seat back videos and
um
you know we had stand-up bars for you
know upper-class passengers and
uh i'm sure lots of romances started at
our at our upper class bars
and we're not the kind of airline that
banged on levatory doors either
[Laughter]
they um
so anyway we were we were a fun fun
lesson number six learn from experience
with grant cardone i spent five years in
college i went to college because i
wanted
i thought the teachers
were going to teach me business
i love teachers okay teachers are great
people but
you can't
know business
if you're in a classroom
it's just it's just not possible it's
like my economics
my economics teacher
uh
there there's no way he could imagine
the the fuel bill on my plane it's just
not real
you go to lord sugar and say hey
how do you make sense of four jets
why would you do that
why'd you buy that building right there
that's the information i want see but
see but most us in this room we were
taught we had to go someplace and spend
four or five years there i'm not trying
to talk you out of school or university
but the fact that it takes four years to
get out of university by itself is it is
a major problem
it's a major problem you know why the
four years i'm trading time for money
what do rich people do
they trade money for time and lesson
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips is do your due
diligence with tillman fertitta when you
think about the fundamentals of a
business when you're going in to
evaluate a deal or whatever
what like key things do you look for
well everything is uh
occupancy cost uh term of lease do they
own any real estate uh what are their
margins uh i'm not real smart but i know
how to do that okay i can analyze the
numbers of any business and tell you
what your margin should be or whatever
because my production cost is this i
have this many subscribers you should be
doing this or that and i don't care what
the business is so that's what i know
how to do
and so
if i try to make the right deal and i do
heavy due diligence and and then
hopefully you can
continue to grow your net worth
i think comparing yourself to others is
actually fantastic i think most people
aren't even doing it enough
the challenge is people do it
incorrectly the problem is people
compare themselves to others as a way to
kick themselves down you look at
somebody else who's done a lot more than
you and you say wow there's so much
better than me i can never do it and
that's kicking yourself down what you
need to do
you flip it and say wow that person has
done so much that's what's possible
i'm comparing my beginning to their
middle or to their end which is an
unfair comparison they can get there
therefore i can go chase my dreams down
as well
that's a kick forward most people kick
themselves down what you need is to kick
forward but without the kick you stay
stuck
so if you want to say exactly where you
are don't compare yourself to anybody
you want to move forward compare
yourself in a loving way forward this is
the classic story of roger bannister who
broke the four-minute mile where it was
supposed to be impossible to break the
four-minute mile nobody was ever
supposed to be able to do it and then he
did it and everybody thought your body
would break down and that it just would
never ever ever happen and then roger
bannister did it and then what happened
lots of other people did it high school
kids did it people around the world have
done it why because they saw somebody
else do it
when you can compare yourself to
somebody else and see that they can do
it that can be
the inspiration to move yourself forward
again the kick forward if you just look
at that and say wow he's superhuman i
can never do it then you're right you
stay stuck but some people the people
who often win the people who also have a
happier life look at that and say
i can do something similar
and people did
i actually heard about that roger
bannister story through les brown and
when people ask me who is my favorite
motivational speaker who who do you
think is the greatest speaker of all
time i say les brown
i don't i don't know who touches les
brown i mean there's so many great
speakers so many amazing people out
there have had a the good fortune of
connecting with a lot of them but man
les brown when he gets on a tear
it's something different he takes you to
a different world and i remember when i
first heard him like holy cow this guy
is so good
and it was at the start of my
career of filming videos and making
content and i thought how does he how
does he know those
scripts and how does he memorize those
lines and how does he just speak for an
hour and not need notes or a powerpoint
or anything else like this man is crazy
it's impossible i could never get that
good
and i used to compare myself in a
negative way like i could never be less
brown
and then somewhere along the line i
flipped it to say hey
i'm getting better
and i love what les is doing because
he's actually guiding
the industry because it's actually
showing what's possible that if he can
do it then i can do it too he's actually
paving the way for people like me to
come up and be speakers as well
and i actually had a good fortune of
last week being on
a facebook live with him where he was
interviewing me about my story like what
les brown is interviewing me about my
story is crazy how did this happen
because i used him
as an inspirational kick forward
see if you never see anybody who's like
you doing it it's really really hard to
get up and do
if you're the only person that you know
on your family and the only person that
you know in your community the only
person you see online anywhere trying to
do the thing that you want to do it's
really really really really hard to stay
motivated but when you can see somebody
else when you can model success you can
have an example to follow
i think that makes the path easier
because it gives you more hope knowing
that it's possible the trick is again
the key is again that in the comparison
of somebody else you're kicking yourself
forward to say that's what's possible
not down to say i suck
so how do you do i'm going to give you
three steps i think will really help
step number one is really get clear on
what is it that you want what is the
life that you want what are the goals
that you have for yourself where do you
want to be in your health and your
relationships and your business your
finances what do you actually want out
of life not what somebody else's perfect
life looks like right you go on
instagram and you see people
living on the beach and and rolling
around in money like that maybe that's
what you want but maybe it's not what
you want and we get pulled into all
these different directions because we
don't have clarity over what we actually
want so what do you actually want what
do you want out of life where do you
want your business to be what kind of
company do you want to run what are the
what are the ethics and morals that your
company is based off of who do you want
to serve and how do you want to help
them how do you want to show up in your
relationship who are you looking for in
your partner if you already have a
partner you know how do you want to show
up better for them
all of the things that matter to you to
get as clear as possible so that when
you see somebody else's doing something
else
and they're happy great you don't have
to go do it because you're happy chasing
down your goals part of the challenge is
we see other people who are happy
and often it's not even real happiness
is just you know fake happiness for the
camera but you see somebody who looks
happy you know that you're not happy and
you think well maybe if i did that then
i'll be happy you know maybe if i go
write a poem like they did i'll be happy
and then you start to write a poem
because i hate writing poems right so
it's getting clear over what do you
actually want in your life who's the
person that you want to be
and again from your finances to your
your business to the relationships to
your uh to health the different areas of
your life get as clear as you can on the
things that you want out of your life
step number two is figure out who's done
it
who's ahead of you in these things
one of the the greatest lessons i've
ever learned is that you can model
success that when you don't know what to
do
somebody has done this before you
somebody has figured this out
you don't have to come up with every
genius idea yourself this is the thing
that ended up growing my business my
first company when i wanted to quit on
my business partner i tried
so many different things on my own
and they never seemed to work but once i
had a model once i had a mentor once i
had a guide once i had a path to follow
it became so much easier and i got
success or looking at my youtube channel
spending five years on my own trying to
figure stuff out then once i got my
agent who gave me some coaching on being
better on camera my channel started to
take off
right so without the model i really
struggled with the model i did really
well
so for all the areas of your life that
you want to fix who's done it and here's
the key there's no one person who's done
everything
and i've got all these people behind me
on the wall
you know this is me
here when i'm eight or nine years old
and my parents behind me and then i've
got different people on my wall for
different things if i look at being a
good father right i've got a 12 year old
son how do i be a great father i want to
be a great father like my dad is and i
don't want to be a great father like
steve jobs is because it didn't sound
like he was a great dad he had a lot of
other great things he was a great
visionary and i want to be a great
visionary like steve jobs but my father
is not really a great visionary so
you're pulling different things from
different people one of the mistakes you
make is you're looking for the perfect
mentor to teach you everything and when
they have one flaw we suddenly feel
cheated or ripped off or deflated
nobody's perfect we're all in search of
our own perfect life and you'll be able
to get that by pulling different people
for different things so once you've made
your list
of all the things that you want out of
your life then go find your different
mentors and role models for those things
if you want more belief in your life
great
watching my channel is probably going to
really really help you if you want more
fitness in your life great there's other
channels you can subscribe to right if
you want a better loving relationship
great there's other channels you
subscribed to for that or books or
podcasts that you can be around that the
more that you're around it the more that
is part of your environment you're gonna
start to take those messages in it's
gonna become a part of you you're going
to think the way those people think and
you're going to get closer to actually
achieving those goals
and then step number three is do
something today
do something today we get
trapped
into overthinking and over preparing and
having the perfect schedule and the
perfect plan
and it almost never works out right your
plan
for what you were supposed to do a year
ago is not the plan that you're doing
right now the perfect plan you're trying
to concoct in your head will never
actually be the perfect plan until you
get out there and start executing and
trying so the biggest thing that you can
teach yourself is just start building
momentum
start taking some immediate action
you've created a list of all the things
that you want out of your life you've
identified your role models of who you
want to learn from to help you go get it
and now three you got to do something
about it you got to take some kind of
action on it if you've got a health goal
great do four push-ups
you know maybe you can only do two do
two push-ups great some of you might be
laughing only two push-ups great do 20
push-ups do 100 push-ups it doesn't
matter is it the perfect fitness plan no
will it actually help you build your
muscles no not from those two push-ups
but what does it do
it starts the ball rolling
it starts to rewire your brain to tell
yourself that you're the kind of person
who takes action and that makes a big
big big big difference because what's
going to happen tomorrow is you're more
likely to wake up and do it again
because you've already started to teach
yourself that you're the kind of person
who follows through
where if you just research and create a
plan
tomorrow you're going to wake up and
probably do no push-ups
because you realize oh that was a silly
plan i can't do that
you're back to who you used to be
and then you don't follow through
so the most important thing once you
identify you get a little bit of clarity
is to take some immediate action no
matter how small no matter how
insignificant it may feel you want to
build a youtube channel great pull out
your phone make a video what are you
going to say it doesn't matter
say i'm working on a certain youtube
channel
i don't know what i'm going to post but
i hope you join me in this journey great
post
the first step doesn't matter how big it
is all that matters is that you took a
step when god created this planet
he created up several species
now if you're an atheist it's okay call
it the force let me just say god for now
so i don't have to say the god the
forest god the forest let's just say god
right now god creates a planet earth and
first of all he creates which a lot of
people in different organizations want a
perfect social economic world where
everything is free don't worry about a
thing you're taken care of there's no
extra imagination necessary it's all
gonna be given to you so he creates the
oyster he says oyster i'm giving you a
free house to live in i'm calling it a
shell i'm gonna put at the bottom of the
ocean
to protect you from your enemies
you have food clothing all the food you
want protection
everything you want the perfectly taken
care of while you're in your measly
little life as an oyster but you're not
going to go anywhere
you stay there at the bottom of the
ocean but you're totally got your free
food free clothing free everything you
want
then god created something called the
eagle eagle whole different species
eagle you want a house you go out and
build it
take the top of a mountain take the top
of a tree go out and build your own
house you want some food to eat no
problem go out there and find it eagle
and the eagle flies through miles in the
wintertime of rain sleet snow and wind
just to feed its young
did you know the eagle
fails 95
of the time a total failure it's so big
and cumbersome that when it comes upon
its prey they're wild they shoot off in
a different direction and it misses
five percent of the time it succeeds and
what does it succeed to do it succeeded
to be the strongest bird in the sky
the only one that we know of anywhere in
the world that could fly into the
thermals of a hurricane and ride them to
have fun
now the eagle unlike the oyster can go
anywhere it wants
anywhere it wants yeah gambles it does
this on its own but it goes wherever it
wants
now that eagle and not the oyster is the
emblem of america
and also on the flag of many many
countries you wouldn't be in this room
right now if you weren't eagles don't
only imagine start doing it thank you
peace love and happiness to all of you
thank you very much thank you
when i worked for other companies some
of them not to mention any names
were so bad they would treat people the
old way i'm the boss here's what you're
gonna do because i'm the boss right or
there were times for example where maybe
had a dollar for lunch you can't get a
lot for a dollar so i just knew that
that's how i was and if i had a company
that i had control of my gosh everyone
was going to be treated the way i wanted
to be treated so the minute we could
afford it everyone had free lunch
whether you had money or not you have
free lunch we pay for it for you carpool
will pay for that so we started doing
things for people that i wish happened
to me
maybe that's part of fate maybe because
a lot of things along the way weren't so
good that as things started getting good
it was so easy for me to share with our
people so easy to do that people
sometimes don't save money as soon as we
possibly could afford it we started
profit sharing we're at the end of every
year and we'll take that profit sharing
and put in a retirement fund for you
it's yours it's yours if you're here so
many years it goes with you no matter
where you go but it's yours that's your
money
that's really incredible and how much do
you think that that sort of golden rule
approach has fed into your
ridiculously low turnover rate which is
literally
almost unprecedented i mean that's crazy
i try and treat people exactly the way
they'd want to be treated exactly or the
way i would have wanted to be treated
i'm happy with my people i realize my
people are the company if my people go
my god the company goes people are your
company and they take care of the
customer the customer is always right no
matter what so what do we do so the
customers happier if somebody's unhappy
would try and discover why
and because you treat people this way
and we love them you walk in our
companies love if you go to the front
desk here in century city this girl just
has the biggest smile saying hi welcome
to john paul mitchell system she loves
what she does
our big problem is
we don't have turnover we have so many
people out of work for us and the thing
is you got to wait for somebody to die
now as we grow we'll add one or two on
obviously at a time sure and we're
pretty big now because we're in 96
countries it's how you take care of
people anywhere in the world you don't
boss them around you including what
you're doing i think you know you can
over
worship and mythologize the idea of
working extremely hard
for my particular makeup
i mean it really is true that i didn't
believe in weekends i didn't believe in
vacations i mean you know i knew
everybody's license plate so i could
tell you over the last month when their
car had come and gone from the parking
lot is so i don't recommend it eh
i don't think most people would enjoy it
uh once i got into my 30s i could hardly
even imagine how i had done that
because by then some natural behavior
kicked in and i loved weekends and uh
you know my girlfriend liked vacations
and that turned out to be
kind of a neat thing
now i take lots of vacations
my 20 year old self is so disgusted with
my
uh current uh
self you know i i was sure i would never
do anything riding coach you know now i
have a plane so it's it's
very much counter revelations have taken
place at high speed
but yes it is nice
if during those first several years
if you have a team that's chosen to be
pretty
maniacal about the company and how far
that goes you should have a mutual
understanding so you're not uh one
person expecting one thing another
person to expect another thing
and you'll have individuals who
who have
you know health or relatives or things
that are distracted but yes i
have a fairly hardcore view
that there should be a very large uh
sacrifice made during those
those early years so for me the
foundational base of empowerment of
entrepreneurship
of any kind of engagement the
foundational base of my success
of my well-being my wholeness my
everything is knowing who i am and where
i come from
in my living room right now
is a painting that i've owned now for 30
years you can google it
it's called to the highest bidder
and it's at the center of my house
and it's at the center of my house
because it actually is symbolic of the
foundation of not the house but the
foundation for my life the painting is
by harry rosalind who was a genre
painter painter in the
early 20th late 19th century
and the painting is over six feet tall
and it shows a slave woman
on the auction block
holding her daughter's hand
and i cannot come in the door my front
door or i cannot leave without passing
that painting i am reminded of where i
come from every day of my life and i am
reminded because i never want to forget
it
and in my library
i have a framed list of enslaved
african-american people remember i
showed you
who were held in bondage
on various plantations
listed in the ledgers alongside
the cows
and the horses
and the buggies and the other property
and i pass this list every day
and often i stop in front of it and just
speak their names
out loud and their ages
jonas
11 years old
500
sarah
41 years old
900
elizabeth
57
800
and i forced myself to consider
the absurdity and the obscenity
of prices being affixed to each one
should they be placed up for sale
and i sometimes just pause before them
with a prayer
particularly before i have to make a big
decision about
one of my companies or
whether i move forward or whether i stay
still
it reminds me speaking those names out
loud
not only of where i've come from
but how far
i have to go
because of them
and it reminds me that i am never alone
it reminds me of what i've come through
to get through there's a really face to
uh threat threat of death
due to the model 3 production round
essentially the company was bleeding
money like crazy and and just
if if we didn't solve these problems in
a very short period of time we would die
and it was extremely difficult
to solve them how close to death did you
come we were within
single budget weeks 22 hours a day or
like what how many hours working yeah
seven days a week
sleeping in the factory
uh worked every everywhere from i worked
in the oaks in the paint shop general
assembly body shop you ever worry about
yourself imploding like it's just too
much absolutely
no one should
put this many hours into work
this is not good
and people should not work this hard i'm
not they should not do this this is very
painful
painful in what sense
uh it's because my hurts my brain
and my heart
so it's this is not recommended for
anyone i just did it because if i didn't
do it then tesla
your chances would die like one of the
most difficult choices i ever faced
uh in life was
was in
um
and um
i think i had uh
like
maybe 30 million dollars left
or 30 or 41 left in 2008 i had two
choices
i could put it all into one company
and then the other company would
definitely die
um or split it
between the two companies
and but if i split it between two
companies then both might die
and when you put your
blood sweat and tears into creating
something
you're building something it's like a
child
um
and so it's like which one
am i gonna let one starve to death i can
bring myself to do it so i
split the money between the two
fortunately thank goodness uh they both
came through you know we all have
adversity in our lives you i i would i
would i doubt if you really you know if
you know somebody any friend or anybody
that you talk to
um
there's no lack of adversity and
the uh and by the way that's good
because it's what teaches us how to get
back up you fall down you get back up it
always happens
and
you know you get certain
gifts in life and you want to take
advantage of those
but you
i guess my advice on adversity and uh
success
would be
to
be proud not of your gifts
but of your hard work and your choices
so you know you may be the kinds of
gifts you get you know you might be
really good at math it might be really
easy for you that's a kind of gift
but practicing that math and taking it
to the next step
that could be very challenging and hard
and take a lot of sweat that's a choice
you can't really be proud of your gifts
because they were given to you um you
can be grateful for them and thankful
for them um and but your choices
you choose to work hard
you choose to do hard things
those are choices that you can be proud
of the secret sauce of amazon where
there are several principles at amazon
but the number one thing that has made
us successful by far
is obsessive compulsive focus on the
customer as opposed to
obsession over the competitor and i talk
so often to um other ceos
and
some other ceos and also
founders and entrepreneurs and i can
tell that even though they're talking
about customers they're really focusing
on competitors and it is a huge
advantage to any company if you can stay
focused on your customer instead of your
competitor in my apartment where we
started 18 founders
and we aim high we have a dream we say
we want to make become the top 10
internet companies or websites in the
world guys at that time we are ranking
several million
names who is it will be number 10 or the
top 10 of the world
we want to make this company last 102
years and we don't know where's our pay
next month
well
when you are poor
if you have dreams you'll never feel
poor
you know what we are doing
so after we never say we will we will
win next year or we win tomorrow we say
we will win in 10 20 years
19 years past today we are the top 10
websites com internet companies in the
world
the african desert every green is that
the ecosystem is not controlled by lions
and elephants
the ecosystem is controlled by the
insects in the mud
last century the company the big the
better so everybody want to be a big
company the powerful company this
century from now on a good company is
more important than a powerful company
when you compete with become i think in
past 20 years we've been competing with
any company lots of companies in china
but i learned one thing
no matter how strong an elephant is
if you're an ant if you hide yourself
well
an elephant cannot kill you
you can kill the elephant if you're in a
better way
it's about your thinking i don't need to
be
in washington to figure out what the
washington post
newspaper has worked and i don't need to
be in new york to figure out what some
other company has worked that's it's
it's simply it's an intellectual process
and the less the less static there is in
that intellectual process really the
better off you are what is the
intellectual process the intellectual
process
processes
is
defining your level defining your area
of competence and valuing businesses
and then
within that area of competence
finding whatever sells at the at the
cheapest price in relation to value and
there are all kinds of things i'm not
competent to value but there are a few
that i am confident
have you ever bought a technology
company no i really haven't
in 30 years of investing not one i
haven't understood any of them so you
haven't ever owned for example ibm never
owned ibm marvelous company i mean a
sensational company but i haven't owned
ibm
and so here is this technological
revolution going on and you're not going
to be a participant going right past me
is that all right with you it's okay
with me
i don't have i don't have to make money
in every game i mean i don't know what
cocoa beans are gonna do
i don't you know there are all kinds of
things i don't know about and that may
be too bad but uh you know why should i
know all about them i haven't worked
that hard on them in securities business
you literally every day have thousands
of the major american corporations
offered you
at a price and a price that changes
daily
and you don't have to make any decisions
you have to make
nothing is forced upon you so you there
are no called strikes in the business
the pitcher just stands there and throws
balls at you
and uh if you're playing real baseball
and it's between the knees and the
shoulders you either swing or you've got
a strike call on you if you get too many
call i know you're out
in the securities business
you sit there and they throw
us steel at 25 and they throw general
motors at 68 and you don't have to swing
at any of them they may be wonderful
pitches to swing at but if you don't
know enough you don't have to swing
and you can sit there and watch
thousands of pitches and finally get one
right there where you want something
that you understand and then you swing
and so you might not swing for six
months you might not swing for two years
i would
i would like to tell you of
two women
that
each sold the business to berkshire
hathaway
uh to me actually for many many many
millions of dollars
both of them started with twenty five
hundred dollars by a coincidence was the
exact same amount it was everything they
had in the world
and one of them
was a woman
who landed in seattle in 1917
couldn't speak a word of english
had a tag around her neck
the tags said
uh
fort dodge iowa
the red cross
got her to fort dodge where she was
reunited with her husband who had come
to the country a couple of years earlier
and she lived in fort dodge for two
years
and as she put it
she felt like a dummy
she couldn't pick up the language she
couldn't learn a word
and so she decided she and her husband
decided to move to omaha
so they came to omaha
in 1919
and there she found a
small colony of russian jews so she
started feeling more at home
and then as her oldest daughter went to
school
she would come home this daughter
francis
and she would teach her mother the words
she learned in school that day
and this woman rose brompkin
spent 20 years
saving money
bringing first her siblings over
her mother and father
fifty dollars at a time she sold used
clothing to do it
she had four children during this period
and by 1937 after 20 years
she'd save 2 500
she went to chicago
and she bought what she could have
furniture her dream had always been to
open
a furniture store
and this woman would who had never gone
to school one day in her life
with 2 500
but with the same spirit that the people
in this room had
about having a dream
and working to accomplish that dream
she built a business
which she sold to me
in 1983 for 60 million dollars
approximately in which
which did a billion and a half dollars
worth of business last year
[Applause]
the fourth generation is working in that
business
this woman rose blumpkin
lived
well she she worked for me until she was
103. and
then she
said then she retired and she died the
next year which is a lesson to all of
berkshire's managers that
premature retirement you know nothing
you can't tell what's going to happen
but mrs b
with her 2500
one further fact about her
she could not read or write
and she went into a furniture business
and she didn't bring anything in unique
in furniture but she brought a
determination to succeed
she knew she could outwork anyone else
she knew she cared about her customers
she worked at very low gross margins but
she built this incredible business you
know i kind of think about what we're
doing today
very similarly to how i thought about
where we were at the beginning you know
it's uh you know i get people all the
time who come to me and say all right
well you're investing billions of
dollars in trying to uh
put internet connectivity and in places
where you know we don't get paid for it
it's not something that uh will that
we'll make any money from for a very
long period of time if it works out but
you know it's this deep belief that
you're trying to make a change you're
trying to connect people in the world
and i really do believe that if you do
something good and if you help people
out then eventually some portion of that
good will come back to you and you may
not know up front what it's going to be
uh but
that's just been the guiding principle
for me in the work that we've done so
throughout building facebook i mean
there have been lots of challenges and
there are all these times where in
anything you do where you know you're
really going to be pushed and you
feel like you want to give up or
something like that and
you know this gets back to
i was talking a second ago about how
i think the media there's a little bit
of this cultural bias towards thinking
that you know one person does this right
i mean people say that you know i built
facebook or steve jobs built apple or
whatever but you know that's really not
true right i mean it's we're we're
people we we helped uh but there were
thousands and thousands of other people
involved in building these things and
the reality is is that as strong as any
one individual is
no one person can deal with all the
challenges that are going to get thrown
at them in anything that you do and
one of the ways that i think we maintain
resilience is by having
co-founders and partners who
complement our strengths and
fortify our weaknesses and can kind of
encourage us and give us a push to to
keep going when things are tough and
there's actually a lot of data on this
that suggests that companies that get
started with more co-founders are more
likely to be successful
and it isn't quite clear
exactly from that data why that's the
case although it is very clear in terms
of the outcome for the startups that it
is the case um but i would guess
that the reason why that's the case is
because of this resilience point where
people who start something by themselves
i just think like there's no way that
any one person can overcome all of the
different things that you need to do to
to build a startup or take on any kind
of other project in the world but if you
have two or three or four partners then
i don't know i mean maybe over time one
of them
doesn't like it and drops out but you
still have enough strength on the team
to power through all the challenges that
you have and that's kind of how you go
you famously started spanx with five
thousand dollars in your bank account
what was the hardest part about getting
spanx off the ground
um the hardest part about getting spanx
off the ground was definitely in the
very beginning when you have when you
first have an idea as an inventor and
you've thought of something that doesn't
exist and you want to bring it into the
world
there were two things that were
happening one was my own self-doubt was
a really hard part of the journey and
and then the beginning of all the
manufacturers that i was having to cold
call and talk to to try to get my
product made were all men and it was
much harder to explain and to try to get
them to understand the concept of what
the product was so i heard the word no
for two straight years trying to get it
made which then increases the self-doubt
that can happen
and one of the interesting things about
being an inventor is you don't go to
school for it there isn't an inventor
class you can't major in inventing and
so it's really a belief system in
yourself and the willingness to look
stupid or to have people laugh at you or
to fail
at something that you believe in you're
your own gut check on that and so it
takes a lot of confidence so that was
that was the hardest part of my journey
there was a lot of starting and stopping
and like am i crazy and everyone's
saying no and but i you know i kept
picking myself back up to pursue it well
growing up my dad used to encourage my
brother and me to fail so at the dinner
table he would actually ask us what did
you fail at this week
and if we didn't have something to tell
him he would actually be disappointed
and i can remember coming home from
school and be like dad dad i tried out
for this and i was horrible and he'd be
like way to go and high-five me
and
what it was such a gift what he was
doing i didn't realize it at the time
but he was redefining failure for me and
so failure became not about the outcome
but about not trying
and
so you know the fear of failure as we
all know as entrepreneurs is one of the
greatest fears in life it's one of the
things that stops us in our tracks and
keeps us from trying something
and so i you know i incorporate that in
my philosophy at spanx we have we
celebrate failures we talk about them we
have oops meetings where i'll announce
the oops that i have and sometimes we
have fun with it we'll even attach
theme songs to our oops
and we'll play them in front of the
whole company but i think it's just so
important to try to get the people that
you work with to take risks and to be
entrepreneurial and not live in a place
of i want to protect my job and feel
like i'm not safe if i make mistakes
today oracle employs around 150 000
people
but when i started
it was not my intention
to build a big company
what happened
well at first we did exactly what we set
out to do
hired the most talented software
engineers in silicon valley we assembled
an all-star team of gifted programmers
who were among the best in the world at
what they did
that team
plus one crazy idea
gave birth to a giant company
i call it a crazy idea
because at the time
everyone told me it was a crazy idea
the idea was to build the world's first
relational database
several theoretical papers about
relational databases had already been
published and ibm was building a
prototype in their research labs
but back then
the collective wisdom of computer
experts
was that
while relational databases could be
built
they would never be fast enough to be
useful
i thought
all those so-called computer experts
were wrong
and when you start telling people
that all the experts are wrong
at first they call you arrogant
and then they say you're crazy
so remember this graduates
when people start telling you
that you're crazy you just might be on
to the most important innovation in your
life there are lots of times especially
in the early days uh that were that were
very very difficult i think i think the
most difficult thing experience i had
was in 1990 when oracle had its
had its only lost quarter in history and
we've been in business for 20 years of
the 20 years we lost money one quarter
and we had a very difficult time um
because we had almo we doubled our sales
virtually every year for for 10 years
nine nine out of ten years ten out of 11
years it was really quite an amazing run
we're the fastest growing company in
history still we still are the fastest
growing company in history over a long
period of time
and
suddenly we'd hit a wall we were we
reached a billion dollars in revenue and
we were having serious management
problems all over the place and
the people who were running the company
the billion dollar company were the same
people that run the company when we were
a 50 million dollar company 120th the
size
and i hadn't
had an incredible sense of loyalty to
those people who'd worked with me to
build oracle
and it was a very painful
realization
in 1990 that i was going to have to
change the management team that the
company had outgrown
the management uh that
people who are good at running a 50
million dollar company are not
necessarily those aren't the same skills
it's not they're just different not one
is better or worse the just entirely
different skill set in running a 50
million dollar company than a billion
dollar company and uh
both skill sets are rare and precious
but we needed a different group of
managers and virtually the entire
management team had to be replaced and
that means i had to ask people who i'd
worked with for a decade to leave i had
to fire people
and that was the most difficult
the most the most difficult thing i had
to do in in business asking that yeah
a bunch of people to
leave oracle
i had no choice
i'd have to ask them to leave oracle or
everyone would have to leave oracle
because there wouldn't be any oracle
left
so it was in that sense it was a simple
choice
it was
uh thousands of people worked at oracle
uh
they deserve the best leadership we
could find
uh
and
my primary my primary responsibility was
to the company and
all of the staff
you know all of our shareholders and all
of our customers
and uh
therefore i had to choose
and if i couldn't make that decision
then i had to go now i'm going through
and teaching myself neural networks and
you know doing the same thing with
machine learning and gans and this and
that because
ai is going to have more of an impact
than the internet did ai plus new types
of chipsets plus 5g is going to change
things far more than we've ever seen
anything change and understanding where
and how to apply it is going to be
critical but just as important knowing
how to sep
segregate and separate
right is as important because every
email you are about to send me
is going to say i have this ai solution
and we're using algorithms
yeah of course you are right and then
what what really makes you different
what really sets you apart but if i
didn't do that work if i didn't sit down
and do the aws machine learning
tutorials if i didn't go on youtube and
take you know the nyu introduction to
neural networks or whatever i'm not
going to know it i'm not going to be
able to apply it and i'm not going to be
able to be first and that's fun that's
fun knowing i get to kick the ass to
some 22 year old nyu graduate that's
awesome i mean my dad busted his ass i
mean he worked six six days a week um
lit left at seven at seven seven thirty
in the morning got back at six or seven
o'clock um lost his eye in an accident
doing upholstery he had a staple break
when he was putting um
some
covering on a car seat um
you know it was it was a middle class
uprinking my mom did odd jobs
you know they they just wanted something
better i mean my grandparents came over
from russia and you know my dad was the
first generation my uncles were first
generation americans like my mom too and
you know like every child of immigrants
they wanted better for their kids you
know it's funny i mean a lot of people
grow up that way right but not many
people end up like you so what do you
think that's the result of
i think
you know
everybody's got something that they're
good at and the hard part is just
finding it
and i found out early that i was a good
salesperson that i really liked business
you know like i like sports i mean i
read everything i possibly could played
sports as much as i could just wasn't as
good as i wanted to be and and business
was the same way i mean as long as i
could remember i was buying and selling
baseball cards garbage bags
whatever i could find stamps
um to collectors
but i was also reading everything i
possibly could about business and you
know i was that unusual kid that i'd
rather read about ted turner than go to
the movies and and so i think that
created a foundation of my parents you
know my dad used to always say i don't
understand what you're doing but i'm
glad you're doing it and and so i have
my ups and downs along the way of course
but um i just think that i just i just
put in the time and was fortunate enough
to really get excited about business and
that paid off benefits over the long
haul one part that i'm always um
very focused on is sort of the structure
of these companies and how how well are
people aligned and so you can um
and making sure that people are you know
aligned properly not just that they say
i think this is sort of a very a very
legal kind of a framework to think about
what are people's incentives you know
are they going to be aligned or not and
i think you want to both have formal
alignment where you set the structure
right and you want to have
informal alignment where the people
would naturally try to work together
well in one one way or another um
and i think that somehow tends to get
obscured in all these other ways um you
know there's always a there's always a
uh there's always a
pre-history question i like to ask
founders of of companies which is um
how did you uh how did you
meet what's the pre-history of the
company before you got started um i find
that to be really instructive a set of
questions to ask a bad answer is
something like you know we met a week
ago
at a social networking function at a
business networking function we decided
to start a company because we both
wanted to be entrepreneurs um you know
that's like saying i married the first
person i met at the slot machines in las
vegas and you might hit the jackpot but
it's probably a really bad idea um and a
much better answer is you know we've
been talking about this for a long time
you know maybe
one of us is more on the tech side the
other one's more on the business side we
have these sort of complementary skills
and uh and so i think this question of
um alignment and structure is um is
incredibly important on an individual
level i think it is always uh it's
always really good if if there's
something that you're incredibly
passionate about and um and just sort of
are find to be intrinsically interesting
and and that that people pursue that um
and so the you know one of the
one of the the the resolutions i came up
with um a number of years ago was to
always uh um value substance over status
substance over prestige um
and you know if i sort of was giving my
younger self advice on what to what to
do or how to how to think about um
your when's one's life i you know i
probably i think i you know um
i probably would still go to stanford um
you know i i might still go to law
school um but i'd ask i'd ask sort of
i'd ask a lot more questions why why i
was doing these things and i think uh i
think if i was honest about it
too much of it was driven by
um by prestige and status and not quite
enough about um really the substance of
uh of trying to learn things and you
know i had sort of this i started to
think of it as this sort of crazy
rolling quarter life crisis and sort of
culminated in this uh in this you know
big new york law firm where you know
from the outside everybody wanted to get
in from the inside everybody wanted to
get out um you know um after i lasted
seven months and three days and after uh
um and uh when i when i when i left one
of the people down the hall said you
know it's so reassuring to see you leave
peter i had no idea it was possible to
escape from alcatraz which which again
uh and you know and again i and all you
had to do was go through the front door
but our identity um people's identities
get so wrapped up in um the things they
compete for that it was inconceivable
for people to actually do that and and
then the question was you know well how
had i ended up there why had i not
thought about that more and and i think
it was um that i had taken too many of
these shortcuts of valuing sort of what
was prestigious what was conventional
over what i uh what i really want to do
so i think i think always substance over
status you know i think that uh
i think there definitely are things that
one can iterate on but the the core
thing is to have a great product and
then you can always improve and and
iterate on that in all sorts of ways and
i think you know i think um even in in
the tech industry um uh what's striking
is how
um
weak on a quantitative basis so many of
the successful companies were it was
just they had a great product and then
years later they were able to optimize
it in all sorts of all sorts of ways
whereas if you're just trying to
optimize and you don't have a great
product
i think that that rarely works um i
think it's always worth asking you know
where you're going to go with this
business um and so i think we're always
focused on very short time horizons
because you have to you know figure out
a way to get through the next month the
next quarter
you know how do you get some customers
how do you how do you track but it's
it's always worth thinking ahead you
know five to ten years you know why will
this be a really valuable business in
five to ten years and um you know how's
the competitive landscape going to
develop how's technology going to
develop how's the world going to develop
um these are hard questions to answer
but i think um i think i think i think
the the great entrepreneurs that i know
always have some perspective on it and
it might be wrong but it's just this is
what's going to happen and then it's
sort of well reasoned and and so you
have a you have a plan it and you know
it's uh when i when i was playing chess
uh you know in junior high school one of
the early lessons i learned was a bad
plan is still always better than no plan
at all right and so
you know have a plan you can always
change it but don't uh don't just
pretend that uh that you have no clue
about what's gonna happen and that
everything about the future is random if
you if you sort of say that everything's
random and out of your control that's
that's that's the way you set yourself
up for failure i think you should be
doing something you're passionate about
so the question is always
you know when i give my younger self
advice you know if would i still go to
stanford or this will go to stanford law
school
um possibly but i think a lot more about
why i was doing it was is it just uh you
know you know i was on this super tract
for myself i ended up at a big law firm
in new york uh in my eighth grade junior
high school yearbook one of my friends
wrote and i know you're going to get
into stanford in four years i went to
stanford four years later went to
stanford law school ended up at a big
law firm in uh in new york where on the
outside everybody wanted to get in on
the inside everybody wanted to get out
when i left after seven months and three
days
um one of the one of the people down the
hall from me said it was you know really
reassuring to see that it was possible
to escape from alcatraz which you know
all you had to do was really just go out
the front door but um but so much of um
our identity gets wrapped up in the
competitions we win
and um that and when you compete
um and i think a lot of the
credentialing resume building is this
sort of competition when you compete you
do get better at what you're competing
at if you take lots of sat test prep
classes you'll get a better score on the
sat
um and when you compete you get better
at beating people on the narrow things
you need to beat them on but um but you
often it often comes at this very high
price of of losing sight of what's uh
what's truly valuable and important and
meaningful
which is
well i think passion there's well
there's sort of all sorts of other there
all sorts of things that that could be
that but but i think
um i think it often
the the i think it often ends up being
uh something that's a little bit off the
beaten path because uh so i think um you
know there's there's obviously financial
version where you get to be have a
monopoly like business
there's a the meaningful version i think
is always counter factual where if you
weren't doing this
would you know it's great to be working
on problems where if you weren't working
on them nobody else would do them you
know if you're working at the fourth
online pet food company the 10th in film
solar panel company the 1000th
restaurant in philadelphia
there's a sense that if you weren't
doing it someone else would um you know
if you're working at uh
at something where
it's the only thing of its kind in the
world that's very meaningful if we
weren't if we and it could be for-profit
non-profit all sorts of context if we
weren't doing this this problem would
absolutely not be tackled i think that's
the kind of
that's what's that's what's meaningful i
know that one of the key things one of
the things that's made me successful in
my life
is making it a priority to control
my thoughts like what what am i thinking
about like literally putting discipline
in on
how i talk to myself
and so i don't want this to sound all
the psycho babble stuff it's not like
it's not like oh if you just stand in
the mirror and talk to yourself and say
positive things everything's gonna be
all right be careful what you say to
yourself okay because if you're saying a
30 steak is a lot of money
or a four dollar toy is a lot of money
when your kid wants a four dollar toy
listen to what you're saying
that's a lot of money
dude four dollars is a lot of money okay
on my worst day four dollars has not
been a lot of money even though
okay i've been at periods in my life
where i didn't have four dollars
so i'm talking to you today about
how do you control
how do you control
how do you discipline
how do you start monitoring what you're
saying to yourself
i can't find the right girl
can't find the right guy there's no good
guys left in this town all men are pigs
women cheat on their men
marriage is hard
having kids is difficult
i don't want to pay taxes
you know
i can't help myself i can't stop
i can't trust myself i never do what i
say i procrastinate i'm an introvert
i'm broke i'm poor
so
look what are you saying to yourself all
the time the first thing i did was i
took a i took a little journal out and i
just wrote down all the negative things
i say to myself by the way i just gave
you the list
okay
i can't spend money
i can't save enough money i don't make
enough money okay i don't know how to
invest in the stock market i can't
invest in real estate i don't have time
to do this you know the time thing
people just kill themselves with the
time thing i don't have enough time i
don't have enough time i don't have
enough time guess what
oops
you don't have enough time you don't
have time you don't have money catch
yourself every time you say i don't have
time
say hey i create time
every time you say i don't have money
i create money
um or maybe just start just start
literally like talking to yourself that
hey i am a millionaire i am a
multi-millionaire i own
if you want to if you're in the
apartment game and you want to be in
apartments but you don't know anything
about apartments you can start literally
talking to yourself saying i am worth
uh uh or i own 100 units i did this for
years for years before i ever bought an
apartment i used to write down i own 20
apartments that earns 12 percent cash
flow
over and over i bet i better wrote this
down a thousand times i own 20
apartments my first deal was 38 units i
own 20 apartments or more
and i write it in any little journal any
piece of paper any legal path every time
you say something negative write down uh
i need to lose weight
okay
that's good but you know if you're
running a race
you don't say i need to finish the race
you're like you're looking for that
you're you gotta run right you to run
you got to move you got to keep moving
your feet so i mean you can sit there
and say i got to finish this race but
the truth is if you need to lose weight
man just once you pick your target
weight
and start affirming
that i weigh 165 pounds
i weigh 165 pounds so just switch it a
little bit right all you're trying to do
is discipline you're trying to move the
river so if you're broke right now quit
saying i am broke
and start saying what you want where are
you going you got to get some haters
you need haters
no school is going to teach you how to
get a hater
okay
high school elementary school colleges
what do they teach
you want to be the most popular person
no you want haters
okay the companies that are hated are
the companies that are exploding
the people that are hated are the people
that explode
if i don't hate you if nobody hates you
nobody knows you
so the reason i'll tweet
for instance when we started we had this
uh that newsletter that i sent out okay
we sent it out every week
we were hitting people once a month
and we started getting complaints you
send stuff out too much
my office came to me we went to twice a
month
they came to me we have more people
pulling off of the newsletter good
double up again
why i want haters
okay so we started sending out one every
week
and then i started a twitter account i
actually had people write grant cardone
social media people grant cardone
is an example of what not to do with
social media
i said freaking
just multiply
just increase it okay we were doing like
four tweets a day good do two an hour
why because i want my competition hating
my guts i want them talking about me i
mean i don't really want hate people to
hate me you understand what i'm saying
about i want them so
so energized that they actually start
pushing me
they start promoting me
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you're special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want seven more amazing lessons from
billionaires check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there my sort of algorithm or
optimization is like okay what set of
things do we need to do
uh to ensure that the increase the
probability of the future is going to be
good yeah and so if we if we have to
solve sustainable energy